hi everyone it's Jerry have a nice
attacking game to share with you that
was played in 1980 between Gary kasprov
on the white end
and slavolab marjanovic
so this was played at the Olympiad
kasparov's first Olympiad
a 17 year old casparov for this game
how does he destroy this Queen's Indian
defense in only 23 moves well
he goes in Gambit style in this one
and that kicks off on this move 7 with
D5 the polgayevsky Gambit what does
white get in return for the pawn well
a square
F5 is no longer under Black's control
because of this capture
what white piece will be optimally
placed on F5
night white is hopping to it
white is also pinning D5
black breaks the pin and is now
threatening to take here this is where
White NOW releases the tension
Knight recaptures
the light's not going to allow this
there we go 10 moves in we have a best
piece in the game this guy here and he's
not easily kicked
if you try and shoe him away with G6
that is
to say the least super risky
to create two dark Square weaknesses
and
maybe be down a dark Square Bishop this
is how white could continue this guy
right here is probably going to end up
being the MVP of the game
you can't play in this way you really
should not play in this way so
black underdevelops the knight in this
one this guy wants to contribute Knight
C3 D5 met with E4 two things additional
pressure
on D5 and a path now for the White Queen
speaking of the White Queen
this was my main takeaway from the game
kasparov's play with his Queen are
really his patience with his Queen
what we can observe in this game are a
couple cases where there is a tempting
move for the White Queen but he refrains
from playing that move
Hattie played
a certain move
with the queen it could very easily have
resulted in a queen exchange and with it
an attack that immediately evaporates
okay
from here we have Bishop F6
e takes DC takes D more development for
white
and Knight B to A6
both players are playing close to a
perfect game when I share the graph at
the end you'll see it's about a
flatliner up until this point up until
move 15 really
uh I was curious about this last move
here it seemed a little bit weird to me
developing the Knight to the edge I
wondered about you know why aren't you
going to C6 or D7
so let's have a look at these two moves
briefly
and we could get a better idea as to
what what the purpose here is of Knight
B to A6
if then I went here white could continue
with Bishop D6 pulling The Rook
to a more accessible Square to a knight
chop here and this is where we could see
a night landing on D6 hitting the Rook
hitting the bishop
this is how white could have continued
if the Knight went D7 and here's an even
simpler line if the Knight went to C6
you could take the Knight straight away
and white is able to regain the material
pounce in the center with Tempo a
position to certainly avoid as black
here two super strong Knights for white
okay
with Knight B
to A6
black is staying strong over the D5
Square these ideas by white to swipe the
Knight and then take on D5 well not so
fast black will be recapturing with the
Knight and there's more support there so
they are connected
alright from here guaranteed productive
move Rook on an open file
Queen D7 still in the computer's eyes
in equal position however
after kasparov's move Bishop H3
the computer says the only way to stay
in the game
is to undo your last move
to go back home in other words this is
not what black plays in this position
very difficult for a human to play in
this way to admit that uh your last move
uh was not a good idea
this is best in this position
in the game the King goes to the corner
there is a threat here with Bishop H3 to
land a check and then win the queen
now this is one of the points here this
position where it may be tempting to
deploy the queen
this is a move that I think May tempt a
lot of players
you're pinning upon you're setting up
this check
just like Bishop H3 you're threatening
to win the queen
but
black could play Bishop to ca in its you
know right around the corner we're
probably going to get some Queen
exchange with this pin on the night
this is a way we this is a path you
could go down and the Queens are simply
exchanged
kasprov goes with Bishop H3 abandons
this main diagonal if you're going to
play in this way
you have to you should almost always be
generating a direct thread to pull this
bishop off the main diagonal when this
guy is still around
you know is there going to be some kind
of battery are we going to get mated
with the black queen getting down here
okay not so fast there is this direct
threat with Bishop to H3 and black gets
out of this check Knight H6
any night move in this position and
there would be Queen takes Bishop
this is now a winning position for white
but with only one move
Can you spot what this move is after
King h8 what does Kasparov play here
feel free to pause the video
okay best move takes advantage of one of
these tactical points in the position
there is a pin in the position
94. it's the D5 Pawn
that is pinned the queen
is unprotected the Knight is poison
there is only one
Defender for the black king on the king
side here this bishop on G6 and white
doesn't even want to see that guy around
94 the king side is ready to be
destroyed
Bishop takes Pawn follows
and no reaction Here by The Rook you
could go with a counter-attacking rook
B1 but Kasparov says let's improve the
Knight this is really as good as it gets
six Tempe required to have these Knights
right where they're at F5 and G5
they are super powerful no time
to take the Rook here
in the game Queen C6 is played if you
take the Rook
Queen H5 and what are you doing about
this
H6 to defend you're definitely getting
hit with this one and mate right around
the corner
okay
black plays Queen C6 is now the time for
Queen H5
no this is another point where you could
go wrong where it could result in a
queen Exchange
if Queen H5 here
black has Queen G6 this was the point
initially I was thinking oh you're
setting something up on the diagonal no
there's this defensive idea along the
sixth rank the queen is covering all the
important squares
this is considered around an evenish
position it's a saving move here for
black
okay
in this game it is first 97 these white
Knights are not yet done having fun
97 hits the queen and takes away
this idea to defend with Queen G6
Queen F6
now do we move the queen you could move
the queen in this position and still be
winning with Queen H5
but that's apparently going to require
the following moves if you play Queen H5
here
and H6 this is apparently the only
uh path something like Bishop here and
then some Knight jumping into H6
some weird moves there anyhow I believe
this is like another position where
running in with the queen developing the
queen straight away probably not the
best choice what is White's move here he
does play the best move and that is
to take the H7 Pawn look at these
Knights
absolute
monsters Landing a fork to the queen and
Rook
and the Knight is poison if you take the
Knight now we're finally ready for Queen
H5 it's hitting with check and the queen
would have to block the queen is going
to fall
suggests first flicking in a check and
then taking either way winning for white
okay
there are no minor pieces around here
helping to defend the king
and white with this last move is
stripping black now of
Pawn defense
it's going downhill fast for black
Queen D4 this is Black's reply I'm ready
to get mated let's please exchange
Queens white says no way
Queens remain on board I'm setting up a
discovered check in comes now G6
another delicate queen move
the only retreating move by white in
this game takes a small
step back
Queen H4 I I misspoke there is one other
retreating move but then it's going to
be resignation Queen H4 if you move
forward here she could be challenged
with Queen G7 white would still be
winning in this position but we're gonna
have some Queen Exchange
white is going to be up the piece at the
end of all this but in this game
it's going to end with the Queen's on
board one simple step back white is now
threatening
to move the Knight I'll land the
Discover check
what do you play here in the game
The Rook is captured
the computer is suggesting this is how
bad it is
suggesting take the bishop or even take
the pawn
that's how bad okay any other option
besides Bishop takes Rook if the King
goes here now you could play to H6 with
check
and then pick your favorite way
uh favorite Square to move the Knight
all of them will be mate
in this game it is Bishop takes rook and
one final move Knight F6
discover check black resigns
if the game continued
this is the only move
and now White
has the pleasant Choice two main twos
do you want to go with
this one
Queen H6
and Bishop G5
or
the more flashy
Knight F5
and queen H6
I don't know both are looking pretty
good
either way
black is toast in this position and look
at this final position isn't it
interesting how every every
white piece is on the king side and
nearly every
black piece is kind of hanging out on
the queen side saying I want no part of
that attack
okay
this was a fantastic attacking game here
by casparov I hope you enjoyed it feel
free as usual to leave any feedback in
the comments section below
and yeah maybe you took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care bye